A glass of wine a day keeps the doctor away!
NNOooooope don't care what the scientists
say, I'm just gonna keep onnnnn drinkin.
Hey everyone, Laci Green here for DNews.
Red wine: it's got super powers right?
It can fight cancer, inflammation, heart disease!
This is thought to be because of 2 key components
in wine: 1, the antioxidants, and 2, the ethanol
alcohol itself.
Red wine does have SOME antioxidants in it,
in particular an antioxidant called "resveratrol"
(which is also found in dark chocolate).
Resveratrol has been widely tested in lab
animals, and scientists found that it improved
animals' heart function, ability to use insulin,
and that it may also provide some protective
effects against diabetes and obesity.
In humans, however, the benefits of resveratrol
hadn't been tested....until now.
A new study published in JAMA Internal Medicine
monitored the resveratrol metabolites in the
urine of almost 800 Italians over the course
of 9 years.
They found that more resveratrol didn't actually
translate into lower rates of cancer, heart
disease, or risk of death.
Womp, womp.
The conclusion?
It probably isn't the antioxidants doing the
trick.
The lead researcher at Harvard said that the
reason the benefits may have been seen in
lab animals and not humans is that it is almost
impossible for a human to consume the AMOUNT
of resveratrol given to the animals in the
study.
In order to consume the same amount, a human
would have to drink 1000 Liters of red wine
EVERY...DAY...which will send you on a nice
little trip to your grave.
Fun fact, the resveratrol health craze has
created a 30 million dollar industry selling
resveratrol supplements.
There's no data on how well they work, but
scientists have noted that, like most supplements,
your body probably can't absorb the antioxidants
in supplement form.
Which means, you're better off eating lots
of greens, beans, and berries than drinking
a glass of wine or taking an antioxidant supplement.
So this research doesn't mean that wine isn't
a heart healthy option -- there are still
many studies demonstrating wine's ability
to raise good cholesterol, lower bad cholesterol,
and protect the arteries from damage.
What we're learning is that it may just be
the case that antioxidants aren't the reason
why the wine helps.
It could be because of a different polyphenolic
antioxidant in the wine, or from the ethanol.
There's already been some research suggesting
that it's small amounts of alcohol that could
be doing the trick, in which case, it's not
necessarily red wine alone that can provide
the protective benefits.
It could be any kind of alcohol!
And MAYBE we see the effect with wine drinkers
particularly because the serving size is small
enough.
We'll keep you updated if we see anymore studies
about alcohol and your heart health.
Thanks for joining me for DNews, I'll see
you next time!